>> Laura: IT IS FRIDAY.
IT IS TIME FOR POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS NOW MESSING WITH OUR
LANGUAGE.
DID WHOOPI GOLDBERG JUST ADMIT
HER OWN ME TOO MOMENT.
WE ARE JOINED RAYMOND ARROYO.
RAYMOND, I HOPE YOU CAN DO THIS
WITHOUT INJURING YOURSELF.
WHAT AM I NOW NOT ALLOWED TO
SAY?
WHAT WORDS CAN I NOT SAY, P.C.
POLICE?
>> WE CAME ACROSS THIS ARTICLE
IN A SAN FRANCISCO PERIODICLE
WHERE THE TERM INDIAN SUMMER MAY
NOT BE USED.
YOU SHOULDN'T USE INDIAN SUMMER.
THE PROBLEM IS THIS.
>> TAKE THOSE DOWN.
>> INDIAN SUMMER MAY HAVE ITS
ORIGIN IN CARGO SHIPS TRAVELING
THE INDIAN OCEAN.
IT MAY HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH
NATIVE AMERICANS.
>> THERE ARE OTHER WORDS WE CAN
NO LONGER USE.
INDIAN SUMMER, SITTING INDIAN
STYLE, OFF THE RESERVATION.
DON'T SAY OFF THE RESERVATION,
INGRAHAM.
BLACK BALL.
>> BLACK BALL.
I USED THAT TODAY.
>> WHITEWASH.
DON'T USE WHITEWASH, YOU WILL
OFFEND ME.
INMATES RUNNING THE ASYLUM.
>> I USED THAT YESTERDAY.
>> AND ONE YOU TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER.
FRESHMAN.
>> YOU CAN'T SAY FIRST YEAR.
>> BECAUSE YOU ARE
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST WOMEN.
I THOUGHT IT WAS LIKE, DON'T BE
FRESH, MAN.
>> A NEW POLL BY A GROUP CALLED
MORE IN COMMON.
THEY FOUND 80% OF PEOPLE, 80%
FOUND POLITICAL CORRECTNESS A
PROBLEM.
WHEN YOU BREAK IT DOWN BY RACE,
79% OF WHITES AND 82% OF ASIANS
AND 87% OF HISPANICS AND 75% OF
AFRICAN-AMERICANS THINK
POLITICAL CORRECTNESS IS A
PROBLEM.
>> THEN, HATE SPEECH IS A
>> 82% THOUGHT IT WAS HATE
SPEECH.
>>> LET'S TALK ABOUT NEIL
PATRICK HARRIS.
>> SPEAKING OF THE P.C. POLICE.
THE VIEW HAD A MOMENT FEW CAUGHT
THE OTHER DAY.
ACTOR, NEIL PATRICK HARRIS,
REVEALED HE DID HIS FIRST FILM
WITH WHOOPI GOLDBERG AND SAID
THIS.
>> I DID MY FIRST MOVIE EVER
WITH WHOOPI GOLDBERG, A MOVIE
CALLED "CLARA'S HEART."
SHE TOLD ME -- SHE TOLD ME I WAS
WHAT, 15, 16 YEARS OLD.
SHE TOLD ME ON MY LAST DAY OF
SHOOTING THAT TEN YEARS, IN TEN
YEARS TIME, SHE WAS GOING TO
HAVE SEX WITH ME.
>> I MIGHT HAVE.
IN THOSE DAYS, YOU COULD
ACTUALLY HAVE SOME FUN LIKE
THAT.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT NOW.
>> I WAS NOT OFFENDED.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO IT.
>> HAVE SOME FUN LIKE THAT.
>> IMAGINE, IMAGINE IF A YOUNG
FEMALE ACTRESS GOT UP AND SAID
SOME ACADEMY AWARD WINNING
DIRECTOR HAD TOLD HER WHEN SHE
WAS 15 THAT HE WOULD HAVE SEX
WITH HER IN A FEW YEARS, THE
VIEW WOULD BE ASKING FOR THAT
GUY'S HEAD AND PROMISING HE
WOULD NEVER WORK AGAIN.
THERE APPARENTLY IS ONE RULE
BOOK FOR HOLLYWOOD AND ONE RULE
BOOK FOR EVERYBODY ELSE.
>> EVERYONE WAS KIND OF LIKE --
>> HO-HUM.
>> THE CAT GOT HER TONGUE.
>> I DID NOTICE THAT.
>> JAMES GUNN WAS THE DIRECTOR
OF THE BIG MARVEL GUARDIANS OF
THE GALAXY.
THEY ENDED UP SLICING HIS
CONTRACT, CANCELING HIS
INVOLVEMENT AND THEY MOVED HIM
TO D.C. COMICS, HE IS DIRECTING
THE SUICIDE.
HE WROTE THESE PEDOPHILETWEETS
AND THEY FIRE HIM AND REHIRE
HIM.
>> CONNOR, LAST MAN STANDING,
WHERE ARE WE ON THAT?
>> IT IS THE BIGGEST P HIT.
IT IS A TIM ALLEN SHOW, A
CONSERVATIVE SHOW.
BOUNCED OFF OF ABC.
IT BEAT THE MURPHY BROWN PREMIER
BY 1 MILLION VIEWERS.
YOU KNOW HOW THEY PUSHED THAT.
WHAT HAPPENED NEXT, IT BEAT
"WILL AND GRACE" THIS WEEK.
THE CONNORS IS IN FULL PASS
MODE.
>> RAYMOND PREDICTED CONNORS
WITHOUT ROSEANNE.
>> THREE OR FOUR EPISODES AND IT
IS CANCELED.